for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so first up is alpha decay what is an
alpha particle an alpha particle
basically is just two protons and two
neutrons we've actually seen it before
in Rutherford's gold foil experiment if
you haven't seen that video I encourage
you to watch it it describes the how we
discovered the atomic nucleus anyway
it's just two protons and two neutrons
and thus it is represented like this
with the little alpha Greek alpha letter
with the mass number of four and atomic
number of two all right so basically
it's a helium nucleus because helium if
you look on the periodic table has an
atomic number of two and a mass number
of four and so it has two protons and
two neutrons that's the helium nucleus
however this is not a helium atom and
there's an important difference between
the two Adam helium atom has electrons
helium nucleus is not we're not thinking
about the atom okay so enough a particle
is just the helium nucleus no electrons
okay sometimes though it's represented
like this as a helium atom to be which
is for some people confusing because
people think oh and alpha particles
helium atom it's not it's a helium
nucleus no electrons so I guess it might
be a little bit more precise or accurate
to to write it out like this right with
the plus 2 because of the two protons
having that charge but I don't really
see that very often I usually see the
first two but I'm going to use this one
just cuz I feel it makes the most sense
it's easiest to use at least that's just
me but if you see these other two they
should make sense to you now the 42 with
the healing without the plus charge
written it's you the plus charge really
charges not really mention much nuclear
reactions because the implication is at
least charges due to the electron is not
really written up here and the reason
why is because it's implied with nuclear
reactions that you're talking about the
nucleus or outside electrons are not
really
considered here anyway let's do an
example with or of alpha decay so here
we're going to start with radium mass
number of 226 and a an atomic number of
88 first thing we should do is calculate
the number of neutrons based on this if
the mass number is equal to the number
of protons plus the number of neutrons
and z the atomic number is equal to the
number of protons we could just take 2
26 minus eighty eight to get the number
of neutrons so if you do that we'll get
138 138 neutrons so what would the
daughter be if this is the parent
nucleus what's the daughter going to be
out after the alpha particle is emitted
well we mentioned that we have to have
the total a on the Left equal to totally
on the right and the total Xena left
equaling the total Z on the right so
what would need to go here as the
daughter let's just to figure out the
numbers first right if the total a has
to equal to 26 over here we already have
four what do i need to add 24 to get to
26 it would be to 20 22 22 plus 42 26
and I already have two down here for the
atomic number so too and I needed to be
equal to 88 so I'll just put an 86 down
here now which element is this going to
be well if you look on the periodic
table 86 you'll find RN that's right on
so that's it for this problem right so
this is the daughter that would that
would show up after this alpha particle
as you made it so let's think about what
happens to the a busy in the end we can
see here that the a drop by for from to
26 22 22 so it decreased by four what
happened to the Z went from 88 to 86
drop by to what happened to the end we
didn't show that so let's show that here
what is the N he or equal if the if here
at the alpha particle 4-2 that's 22 26
minus 8086 is 22 22 minus eighty six is
136
so the number of neutrons went from 138
to 136 so it decreased by 2 so it makes
sense that Z being the number of protons
and being in of our neutrons each of
them decreases by two because the alpha
particle is two protons and two neutrons
and they're leaving the parent nucleus
to become the daughter stituted to
result in the daughter and of course the
mass number is made up of the Z in the
end so it decreases by four because both
of these decrease by two each the
general form then is often written like
this maybe the word often is not the
best word to use I don't know how often
I see it but the general form can be
written like this where basically if you
start with some parent the daughter will
look like this right the mass number
will decrease by for the atomic number
will decrease by 2 so that is the
general form here a little cloud around
it okay so there might be the question
of when does alpha decay actually her
alpha decay is common among heavy
unstable nuclei unstable didn't have
enough room there heavy unstable nuclei
are basically everything with an atomic
number greater than 83 which is
everything beyond bismuth is radioactive
and can undergo alpha decay right so
they're heavy and unstable basically
that means they have a bunch of whatever
is contributing to the mass of that
nucleus right so alpha decay occurs when
a nucleus has too many protons and
neutrons that should make sense because
protons and neutrons are are what make a
nucleus or an atom heavy right so
because they're the the massive
particles minute so when when you have
something really really big right these
things that have large atomic numbers
and have lots of neutrons lots of
neutrons lots of protons they can
undergo alpha decay to get rid of some
of their protons neutrons to become more
stable okay so that's pretty much outfit
okay hope that video is helpful thank
you for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to Like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying